l'europe divisés sur la réponse
économique à la crise du coronavirus les
ministres des finances de la zone euro
continue de se diviser sur les moyens à
mettre en oeuvre face à la récession qui
s'annonce la pire depuis 1945
retour au mécanisme européen de
stabilité corona vent impliquant une
mutualisation des dettes
les blocages sont nombreux alors que
peut-on encore attend de lui et de ses
institutions dans sept lycées ce que
l'on voit tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir en direct par
skype
bonsoir jacques un confinement oblige
vous êtes loin de moi est loin de ce
plateau j'espère que vous allez bien
quand même jeanne bonsoir beaucoup vous
aussi je le regrette et donc nous allons
travailler par sky exactement alors
jacques on a l'impression qu'en ne rend
pas le pouvoir et est revenu aux états
dans cette crise est ce également votre
sentiment
eh bien oui stéphanie il est clair que
les centres de décision sont aujourd'hui
bien plus dans les capitales de chaque
état qu'à bruxelles
ça ne veut pourtant pas dire que l'union
européenne soit complètement impuissante
elle agit mais elle agit très timidement
et il faut le lire avec beaucoup de
retard alors elle a certes pris des
mesures comme la suppression des droits
de douanes communautaire à l'importation
de matériel médical c'est très bien mais
c'est très peu et en fait le problème
c'est que les questions qui sont posées
par cette épidémie ont réactivé des
débats internes qui ne sont toujours pas
résolus et rien ne dit en vue de la
dernière réunion de l'eurogroupe qui
puisse être réglé rapidement
alors ça cas que cet hymne donc à passer
en ce début de semaine lors de la
réunion de l'eurogroupe
il faut commencer par rappeler que
l'eurogroupe qui réunit les
gouvernements des pays de la zone euro
n'a pas d'existence légale
il n'est mentionné en tant que tel dans
aucun traité c'est pour tous le nez une
instance alors une instance de fait et
non une instance de droit
ce qui est très important et pour la
zone euro bien entendu mais aussi pour
l'union européenne est alors la réunion
qui a eu lieu bon ces derniers jours
devaient notamment discuter de la
proposition franco italienne d'émettre
ce que l'on appelle des corona bon alors
évidemment pouvez-vous jacquin vous
voyez la question arrivait que se cache
son ce nom barbare pas barbare mais
d'appellation de corona bond
oui on comprend ses fans y aller corona
bon c'est quelque chose qui va être liés
à l'épidémie du coronavirus alors par
kuroda bon on entend des bons du trésor
qui seraient émis directement par
l'union européenne ou par un autre
organisme par exemple dépendant de la
zone euro pour trouver de l'argent qui
serait alors mis à la disposition des
différents pays de l'union européenne ou
de la zone euro ce qui fait que ces pays
pourraient emprunter aux taux les plus
bas et non pas aux taux qu'ils doivent
payer s'ils veulent s'endetter
directement en fait c'est un mécanisme
qui revient dans les faits à une
mutualisation des dettes
c'est d'ailleurs une vieille demande de
la france et de l'italie
on avait commencé à en parler de cette
fameuse mutualisation des dettes dans un
contexte tout à fait différent lors de
la crise des pays du sud de la zone euro
en 2010 2011 et qu'à décider
l'eurogroupe et bien stéphanie pour
l'instant je dis bien pour l'instant
rien du tout
l'allemagne l'autriche les pays-bas ont
jusqu'à maintenant bloquer les corona
bon alors ça montre que les possibilités
sont en fait très limité on sait bien
que le confinement est en train de
provoquer une crise historique
une crise terrible dans les économies
cette crise aura donc aussi et c'est une
évidence une traduction budgétaire très
importante il faudra d'après une étude
d'unicredit trouvé entre 1000 et 1300
milliards d'euros supplémentaires pour
les budgets des différents pays
par exemple il faudra trouver quelque
chose comme au moins 300 milliards pour
la france
probablement une somme à peu près
similaire pour l'italie ou n'utilise pas
les couronnes ah bon il faudra à ce
moment là pensez au mécanisme européen
de stabilité le ms alors de quoi
s'agit-il au juste
alors le mv stéphanie c'est ce qu'on a
appelé un temps le fameux fmi européen
c'est avec l île qui permet à l'union
européenne de prêter des sommes
importantes à des états l'espagne la
grèce ont pu en bénéficier
mais bien entendu sous des conditions
qui sont très sévères le ms
il est à l'origine des fameux mémorandum
qui ont été imposées au gouvernement
grec
à partir de 2012 et c'est pour cela que
le ms n'a pas très bonne réputation
effectivement et donc ce mécanisme
jacques que l'on voudrait imposer des
pays comme l'italie et la france
alors on fait la france et l'italie
seraient d'accord pour que l'on active
le ms colon qu'on leur en force parce
que le ms pour l'instant n'est prévu
qu'avec 400 milliards d'euros ce qui est
très insuffisant par rapport aux besoins
mais à la condition justement qu'ils
soient sans condition tu fais de la
situation exceptionnelle qui a été créée
par l'épidémie du coronavirus mais ici
encore l'allemagne les pays bas puis
d'autres pays refusent cette idée d'un
ms sans condition alors la commission
européenne a proposé une forme de
compromis à mls avec des conditions
adoucie mais pour l'instant la france et
l'italie ont refusé
mais alors que peut faire l'union
européenne dans ces conditions alors
l'union européenne a fait une
proposition pour financer par exemple le
chômage partiel qui d'ailleurs rien
qu'en france touche désormais
pratiquement six millions de personnes à
ce jour
elle propose de créer un instrument le
sur1 sur cet instrument prendra la forme
d'un prêt adossé à des garanties
fournies par là encore les différents
états membres de l'union européenne
seulement le gouvernement italien a déjà
déclaré qu'il n'était pas favorable à ce
weekend in qui lui semble à la fois
lourd
coûteux et qu'il préfère en réalité les
corona bon alors les coraux n'est bon ni
les allemands si on a bien compris ni
les néerlandais n'en valent fin
d'histoire donc alors oui et non parce
que en réalité il y à d'autres d'autres
possibilités
prenons par exemple le cas de la banque
centrale européenne christine lagarde a
sorti les grands moyens tout d'abord
pour soulager les entreprises mais aussi
les banques qui sont très durement
attaqué ces derniers temps sur les
marchés financiers elle a décidé
d'accroître le programme de la bce de
rachat des dettes privées
ensuite elle a mis en place un programme
spécial
le ppp alors ça veut dire le pandémique
et madden ses punchs un programme doté
pour l'instant de 750 milliards d'euros
et qui va racheter directement la dette
émise par les états sont tenir compte
des limites qui avait été fixé en 2018
alors jacques ce n'est pas un petit peu
une forme de création monétaire
interdite
si je ne m'abuse par les statuts de la
bce oui c'est fanny c'est évident sauf
que tous les interdits ont de fait
sauter les uns après les autres que ce
soit en 2010 2013 lors de la crise
d'endettement des pays du sud de la zone
euro
que ce soit en 2015 avec la politique de
mario draghi vous avez le le fameux
bazooka monétaire que ce soit
aujourd'hui
alors il est clair que la bce est en
train de s'aventurer dans des eaux qui
sont encore largement inexploré et elle
pourrait d'ailleurs être rappelé à
l'ordre par une action en justice d'un
ou de plusieurs des états membres vous
pensez peut-être à l'allemagne bien sûr
mais il n'y a pas que l'allemagne qui
pourrait réagir
vous avez les pays-bas vous avez la
finlande l orge à quel bilan tirez-vous
de de cela eh bien c'est fini
l'idée d'une union européenne fédérale
vous savez c'est cette idée qui est
défendu par exemple en france par
emmanuel macron a probablement été l'une
des victimes collatérales du coronavirus
les vieilles opposition et parfois il
faut bien le dire malheureusement les
vieilles haines ont immédiatement
ressurgissent devant la crise les
politiques ont été immédiatement
renationaliser les gouvernements
décident plus ils viennent présenter à
la facture à bruxelles ou à francfort
mais la coordination entre les
politiques gouvernementales est
aujourd'hui extrêmement difficile et
nous vivons en fait une crise historique
temps de la construction européenne que
de la zone euro merci et jacques pour
toutes ces explications qui donne comme
d'habitude à réfléchir merci à vous